we come here tonight to sacrifice the
body of Jennifer from Devil's no please
please
please let me go I'll do
it hard it is
to make it as an indie band these days
I mean there are so many of us and we're
all so cute and it's like you don't get
on Letterman or some stupid soundtrack
you're screwed all right Satan is our
only hope it was such an incredible
thing to be able to like make this movie
yeah be together be with an incredible
cast be with an incredible group of of
collaborators and Artisans and
um
but I don't think we knew it would take
the path no way say it like you mean it
say I'm better than needy what why
in the gym needy looks as though she's
had a revelation look pure her or horror
crosses her face she drops her cup juice
splatters onto the ground chip
she rushes toward the exit tripping in
her high heels in the park Jennifer
stands and leads trip toward an
abandoned fenced off community pool it's
drained and spooky and looks dangerous
if even when we were little we used to
steal my toys and pour lemonade on my
bed okay and now I'm eating your
boyfriend see at least I'm consistent
why do you need him huh you could have
anyone you want Jennifer so why chip is
it just to tick me off or is it because
you're just really insecure I am not
insecure God what a joke how could I be
insecure I was a snowflake Queen yeah
like two years ago when you were still
socially relevant I am so
and when you didn't need laxatives to
stay skinny
I am gonna eat your soul and it out
Liz Nikki you and I we both loved the
movie from from the beginning of its
Journey all the way through its sort of
catastrophic release until now like we
we I mean can I say that it was really
hard for us
um and and for everybody who was
involved but we never stopped loving it
most occult Scholars don't know this but
if you're bitten by a demon and you live
you just might absorb some of the Demons
abilities
in the Moonlight we see needy still has
an infected looking bite mark near her
shoulder she scratches at it wincing you
just might get lucky for once in your
miserable life